la farmacéutica estadounidense moderna
anunció el 16 de noviembre que su vacuna
tiene un 94 5% de efectividad
cerca de 30.000 voluntarios participaron
en la última fase del ensayo todos ellos
en la unión americana sólo cinco
personas de los que recibieron la
fórmula y no el placebo se contagiaron
la vacuna de moderna requiere de dos
dosis espaciadas 28 días y tendría un
valor de unos 25 dólares la inyección
requiere almacenamiento de a menos 20
grados centígrados y puede permanecer en
un refrigerador hasta 30 días lo que
facilitaría su uso en zonas remotas
la vacuna de modernas utiliza material
genético para crear la proteína del
corona virus para aprender a producir
anticuerpos el 9 de noviembre
científicos del laboratorio
estadounidense pfizer indicaron que la
vacuna que trabaja en alianza con la
empresa alemana beyoncé que tiene un 90
por ciento de efectividad la vacuna
tiene la misma tecnología que moderna
pero necesita ser almacenada a menos 70
grados centígrados 40.000 personas
participaron en las pruebas de esta
inyección fue la primera vacuna
anunciada registrada por vladimir putin
en agosto pasado sin evidencia clínica
previa tiene un 92% de
actividad requiere de dos dosis y ha
sido probada en venezuela filipinas y
serbia todas están aún sujetas a
estudios antes de pasar a la cuarta y
quinta fase sin embargo un valor de 90
por ciento de efectividad excede todas
las expectativas pues muchos esperaban
que la vacuna contra el coronavirus no
fuera superior a la de la influenza que
fluctúa entre el 40 y 60 por ciento